and when I was 11 I had a casting
director tell me that I wasn't strong
enough to carry my own show I've had a
lot of people try to tear me down but
I'm here I never took a moment to just
go go away and be myself and figure it
out or not meant to put a goal on your
life you're not meant to say once I get
there I'll have it all I think the
definition of strength is being
vulnerable and being honest you've got
to go and explore and explore who you
are and find out what it's about and
what you like and what you don't like
she's an American singer and actress she
came to prominence after being cast in a
Disney Channel series Wizards of Waverly
Place she embraced an increasingly
mature image with the 2013 of her debut
studio album stars dance
she's Selena Gomez and here is my take
on her top 10 rules for success there
are so many great ones that it's hard to
choose but if I had to pick I'd go with
number one as my favorite and make sure
to stick her on all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips and when I
was 11 I had a casting director tell me
that I wasn't strong enough to carry my
own show and I'm sure all of you have
been told that you don't have what it
takes and that you may not be good
enough and you don't have enough people
supporting you and you're being told all
of these things when deep down it's all
you want to do you want to be a part of
something great you want to make
something great and it does more than
knock the wind out of you it crushes you
when people tried to tell you that
you're not good enough and it almost did
for me but there was my mom next to me
stronger than ever and she said the most
important thing is to always trust in
myself if I have if I'm doing something
because I love it I should do it because
I love it and I believe I can do it so
she told me to keep
she told me and she taught me to turn
the other cheek and let the credits
earned like the critics be critics and
let us just trust ourselves so for me
thank you
two years later I got my own show and
the first thought the first thought
wasn't oh man
that girl when I was 11 said I wouldn't
carry my own show and I did I mean I
thought about that for a little bit but
I thought about what my mom said my mom
was like you have to trust yourself and
I realized if I didn't believe that I
could do it I wouldn't be able to be
here I think I've been doing this long
enough to realize that no matter what
people perceive of me I always shine
through at the end of the day so I've
had a lot of people try to tear me down
so but I'm here and I have always been
myself and I've always wanted that and
I've been graceful and I've tried to
handle myself with as much class and
it's only because I know how hard I work
and I'm not gonna let any of that get to
me grab a dream
I don't know I don't want to say it's
one thing I just want to constantly have
goals to keep reaching them because I
don't want to stop if I feel settled
then I won't keep going
so yes personally there's a lot of
things I'd love to do in my life and
professionally I feel like I've just
begun so this a lot when you wake up in
the morning you say okay a year ago I
didn't think this or know this what is
it how to love myself first and not just
in a relationship in my everyday life I
give myself so much I let people pull at
me in every direction and I want
everybody to be happy and eventually I
would I mean I would be in my bathroom
sobbing right before I'd go on stage and
then I'd just put myself on stage and
I'd want though I'd want to be there for
those people I never took a moment to
just go go away and be myself and figure
it out I kept pushing myself and I think
the biggest thing I learned is it's okay
I'm gonna stop when I need to stop I'm
gonna feel when I need to feel and I
don't care what comes with that or what
people want to say it's normal I'm
supposed to keep going and I just wanted
that's all I want to do not meant to put
a goal on your life you're not meant to
say once I get there I'll have it all I
think that that's the biggest lesson
I've needed to learn is how to be
present in that moment and to know that
I'm always going to strive for something
I think everybody who's watched my story
they've seen that not everything has
kind of been handed to me and and I've
been honest about everything some of the
things that haven't been me in the past
and other things I've been so passionate
about and so spot-on with so if anything
that's what revival represents it's that
I feel the most confident I've ever felt
and it goes like that like it's
constantly changing and I don't know I
think that's just that's what I want it
to feel like there's a real difference
with revival though isn't there because
it really reflects on a lot of what
you've been through over the last few
years and there
some songs on there that have much more
deep earthy yes what was that like for
you putting that out there was the
process of putting the album together
quite cathartic yeah I think the
beginning of my career it was very
tailored it was very precise sharing the
vulnerable raw messy side wasn't
necessarily in college yeah
you take them sort of it on a whole it's
quite actually empowering and it feels
like you find in your voice absolute
little bit and also I guess being
prepared to be on your own as well
there's vulnerability
yeah there's vulnerable of strength is
being vulnerable and being honest and
that doesn't mean you have to be like
I'm strong I'm amazing look at you no
look at me
you can have those moments but you won't
have those moments unless you're like
I've been broken I've felt things I've
messed up a lot and I'm okay saying none
for many young stars who have had a lot
of success at a young age sometimes they
get on the wrong path mm-hmm how do you
stay on the right path you are who you
surround yourself with I know that's
such a cliche quote but it's true I've
just witnessed it too much it's easy to
get caught up because of course you're
you're thrown things you're given things
that are fun and exciting but it's just
at the end of the day success is nothing
if you don't have the right people to
share it with you're just gonna end up
lonely first of all congratulations on
just world domination I'll say that's
really what you are on like this tour is
gonna be huge how excited are you I'm
really excited to be honest in the best
possible way I really haven't been able
to sleep or eat anything I mean I'm
taking care of myself but it's crazy
when you when you really believe in
something it's so different and not to
say that I didn't believe in anything in
the past
I just didn't know what I was what my
purpose was I didn't know what I was
meant to say how I was supposed to say
it and then once I started experiencing
so much and I knew people were wanting
to know what I felt and I was scared to
be honest and now to see it come to life
it's crazy
everybody's path is different you know
everybody's gonna do things differently
so honestly I'm I understand when you
need to be free it's like everybody when
you're younger and you
to experience something and you want to
feel real things you've got to go and
explore explore who you are and find out
what it's about and what you like and
what you don't like so everybody's
different and I'm just knocking on wood
hoping that it works out because it's
never an easy transition being a kid
transitioning into adult
it never ends the journey yeah I mean
when do you stop growing you keep going
sometimes you have to just say like why
would you want to make the situation
miserable uh-huh I go to photo shoots
and I actually working with Pantene they
were so sweet and I just like you're so
nice and and they they said that to me
as if that was shocking and I looked at
them I'm like why would I want to make
this miserable for you and me like we're
taking pretty pictures I'm flinging my
hair around like it's you have a choice
yeah it's like if you want to be happy
be happy and that's so hard to do
sometimes but it's something that I just
have come to terms with more than ever
lately in my life and I think people
just see that
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because who Sam as he
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur
you want me to profile next leave it
down in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know which
is Selena's top ten rules the biggest
impact on you on why what change you're
now going to make after watching this
how do you feel after watching all those
inspiring Clips leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
tell me about the first time that you
decided said to yourself you know what I
love to act I want to act I think I
always knew that I wanted to do it plus
it was an only child so I basically
entertained myself
I was super dramatic and always wanted
to put on a show for everyone I actually
held auditions for my friends and
wanting to like past plays like my mom
and I mean my mom was probably a little
bit of an influence in that because of
the theatre background I loved watching
her do her own makeup and run the lines
in the mirror and then she'd kind of
noticed and it'd be like oh Lord
she's gonna be an entertainer it's an
interesting the way it starts there's
some moaning at the beginning which
makes it which one the first song in the
record birthday don't know the title is
no one told me the titles just heard the
record what is it called look at that
exclusive birthday yeah you say birthday
in a lot but that's a very mature
progression sonically to add those kind
of moaning sounds as opposed to being
that the Disney person you you've been
known to be over the years sure but I
mean I'm not messing yeah yeah no Mars
no I think I think more I think it's
more me being able to experiment you
know being going into the booth and
actually having the confidence of being
like alright let me try this let me see
if this works and messing around with
melodies or just harmonies or as you say
moaning is that it wow that's what it is
isn't it guys I guess that's the right
term for it in a way but um ya know I
think in a way I really was able to just
play and that's that was fun for me it's
all on how you choose to live your life
because you can allow yours oh this one
yes I do I choose to live this life but
I also choose to live it the way I want
to live it cuz it's too easy to say that
I want people around me that will tell
me yes and think everything around me is
perfect because I can have those people
around me right now
but I'd rather have people around me
that tell me I don't look good or I
should work out or that sounded stupid
you know I like having real people that
that make me feel like a normal person
because then it makes it easier to be me
so I don't know I hope there's more of
that I'd rather just have real people